vi porto con me alle Maldive Io e Salvo
abbiamo preso un volo diretto da
animalee alle 6:00 del mattino Questa è
l'alba del finestrino il volo durava 4
ore e io avrò dormito 3 ore e mezza mi
sono svegliata E questa era la vista una
volta atterrata i 30 gradi delle Maldive
mi hanno dato il benvenuto Infatti
appena sono arrivata alla lancio del
nostro Resort mi sono un attimino
derutata ci hanno accompagnato al
transfer che come potete vedere era una
barca sobrissima il viaggio è grato
circa 30 minuti e una volta arrivati
L'accoglienza è stata super carina ci
hanno fatto indossare queste collanine e
ci hanno offerto l'acqua di cocco Poi ci
hanno fatto salire sulla Golf car e ci
hanno accompagnato nella nostra
Palafitta e quello sono entrato pensato
Alla faccia della Palafitta sono rimasta
davvero scioccata perché è gigante
Fatemi sapere se volete un tour della
nostra Villa galleggiante baci